Stargate has been a part of my life for
such a long time I remember the first
time I ever watched it I was hooked
instantly
today I just want to talk about why I
love Stargate and why I'm super excited
for the potential of it to return
and everything in between
so welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so these kind of videos that I sit down
and I talk to you and I give you my
feelings on on certain topics around
Stargate
um genre seems to do really well you
guys seem to resonate really well with
them
I thought I would sit down and talk
about the first time I watched Stargate
um and how I fell in love with this
television show
because it's influenced my life in so
many ways uh Beyond just a television
show
um it inspired me creatively
uh it inspired
um a love of programming which is
something I'll get into very shortly but
without Stargate
I don't think
I would be where I am today I don't
think I would have the passions that I
have
today so let's talk about
why why do I love this television show
this show that's not been on the air for
12 years
why is it had such an impact on my life
well I've always been a fan of sci-fi
I've always been a fan of
things like aliens and spaceships and
Big Space Battles and things like that
the first time I ever watched Stargate
would have been
probably around about 2003 or 2004 so I
12 or 13 years old so you can you can
kind of work out how old I am from that
I didn't watch it from the very
beginning at first
um I was watching it as it was airing on
Sky TV
um in the UK
I instantly fell in love I can't
remember what the first episode I ever
watched was
um but I do remember there was a person
in my life at the time
um who introduced me to the show
um
we sat down together we watched it and
it instantly became
at the time one of my favorite
television shows my favorite show would
have been Doctor Who but Stargate has
been such an such an eventful
uh Catalyst in my life that I could
safely say it's probably my favorite
show now
anyone who watches this this channel
will know that I love Doctor Who uh it's
not a secret that I really I love dog
dude the same person who introduced me
to Stargate also introduced me to Doctor
Who back in 2005.
um when the Revival hit we both sat down
together we watched it and it was
something we could bond over and it was
great absolutely loved it
the thing I think I really loved about
Stargate when I first started to watch
it was it felt like it was happening it
felt like
it felt like everything that was
happening in the show could have been
happening in the real world it was it I
didn't realize it at the time but it was
very
I didn't know the word for it I just
felt like it was familiar like it was
something that could happen but
obviously the word for it now is it was
very grounded in reality it was very
cemented in this could actually happen
this is something that could be
happening right now and we would have no
idea about it and that always interested
me that always intrigued me in it uh I
I've always just loved the idea of the
government having a secret Stargate and
we're just going to other worlds and
we're meeting alien races we've got
spaceships out there that no one knows
about and
humanity is greater than what we give it
credit for
Stargate was always one of those shows
that I could
come home from school
and I could watch it in the evening
because I think it was on around about 6
p.m 7 P.M in the UK something like that
so I'd always sit down in the evening
and I'd watch it
um if I didn't watch it straight away I
would record it on Sky Plus
and I'd watch it as and when I could
I eventually did manage to get the
Stargate DVDs
um and that's when I watched every
single episode from the beginning all
the way until the end
I've since watched every single episode
hundreds of times hundreds of times I've
I go through a rotation I know a lot of
you guys do exactly the same thing where
we we go through sg1 we go for Atlantis
we go for Universe we watch all three of
the movies and then we want to watch
some we want to watch it all again so we
just do we just carry on watching and
that's something that I do personally I
just carry on watching it because it
honestly is
my favorite television show
now I mentioned that Stargate was
instrumental in my love of coding and
programming
and the story behind that is there was a
platform
um called Beyond it still exists today
beyond.com build your own net dream
and essentially it was a platform where
you could create your own 2D games
they're multiplayer games so you could
interact with you could have a community
around these games and you could have
people playing them
at the time there was a game called
Stargate online
uh the Creator uh his online name was
yojita so he obviously was a big fan of
Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball Z is very
prevalent on Beyond but he had a game
called Stargate online and
one of my friends from school actually
told me about it um because we we both
enjoyed Stargate and
we started playing
now thankfully
at the time this was
quite a negative thing that happened and
I was I was looked down upon for it
um but someone essentially was given the
source code for this game and we started
hosting our own versions of it it was
called ripping we basically ripped the
game and we started hosting our own
versions but
what that led to
me being able to go into the the code of
this game that I really really enjoy
playing was I learned
how to read code first and foremost and
edit things to make
make things happen the way I want it
I wanted to learn more I wanted to know
how I could add things to it not just
change things and change some icons and
change some text I wanted to add things
to the game
so I started to learn to code
now Beyond is written in
it I can explain it as a derivative of C
plus plus
it's a very very watered down version
very watered down it's very very basic
but it was
it was very easy to use and
that ease of use led me to get
get to know my way around programming
languages understanding the syntax
understanding the logic of how computers
work and how computers handle operations
um
I've gone on to
create many many things with with code
and I do it a lot in my current job I
currently work in it
um
and this skill has helped me
tremendously and it would never have
happened
had I not been as invested in Stargate
had I'm not a fan Stargate online and
had I not been given the source code
however illegally that might have been
and started tinkering I think a lot of
geeky people
um
at least back in the day I'm sure
people's do it now we we we like to
Tinker
so that might be with source code from a
popular project like an open source
project or something nowadays because a
lot of things are open source
um it might be from something that
you've acquired illegally but it's gonna
fuel a an interest and a passion
and I can honestly say without Stargate
that passion that fire in me would never
have been lit
and my passion for wanting to
learn more about computers and I.T and
everything that goes with it probably
wouldn't have happened either
so Stargate has had a tremendous impact
in my life a tremendous impact
and
yeah I'm interested if you guys have any
similar stories do you did any of you
ever play Stargate online do you know
who yujita is do you know uh Gat dude
Gat dude who famously spell his username
wrong he wanted to be gate dude but
didn't put an e he was the one who
ripped the game and gave it to everyone
essentially
so without gut dude thank you Gat dude
you uh you inspired my love of coding
and
yeah do you guys have any similar
stories let me know in the comment
section down below I'm sorry this video
is a little bit different to what I
would normally post but I thought I
would
let you get to know me a little bit more
and uh
yeah just talk about Stargate because it
has had such a such an impact in my life
and thinking about all the decisions
I've made in my life I can attribute
them to starting out with the spark that
came from Stargate and it's such it's
such a good show and this is why I'm so
excited afraid to potentially coming
back
because I want it to inspire another
generation I want more kids like me to
be inspired
So yeah thank you for watching I'll see
you next week
[Music]